hey guys  great news it's available  bodegacatspirits.com you can pre-order  it now it should ship in september if  that link is not working for you for  whatever reason  follow the link in the uh in the youtube  right now right it should be there oh  yeah so follow that link if this one's  not working for whatever reason it  should work if it doesn't follow that  link bodega cat is available it is the  best whiskey in the game right now it's  so good it's selling like hotcakes the  comments are flooding in people love it  it tastes great make a drink make a  cocktail drink it straight on ice  whatever you like drink it gay who knows  but  it's a hell of a rye  and you gotta get on board have a drink  tilt the cold one and listen up  bodega cat